myself obviously I've had long-term  relationships so I'm fine but  what I will say is for the younger  generation  it's very difficult to have a low body  count now because and it's it's because  of older women not even you lie to the  younger women  can I just let me just say something  you've got time like you're staying  dating and we're staying connections and  we're giving out all this there's so  many people the social media has ruined  dating it's like there's so much variety  there's so much what you should be  expecting what you shouldn't be  expecting so it's so fickle dating is so  fickle now how how are young girls  expected to keep their body count down  when but there's there's no  relationships now like it's not like  back in the day where you had a  long-term like relationship mostly our  age were the last of the long-term  relationships I'm not gonna lie man